bring in joe koncha fox news contributor
joe doesn't this play
right into republican messaging i.e
fire pelosi
is
very
motivating i'm sure todd
for some folks to get out if that is the
added incentive but you see the
democratic message now right you have to
vote in this election because democracy
is at stake they don't have the bumper
sticker on all the things people really
really care about inflation and crime in
the border and education and the
democratic party by the way has a leader
uh right now in the oval office that's
79 years old with an impossibly light
work schedule by the way a 71 year old
senate majority leader in chuck schumer
and as todd just mentioned or excuse me
as griff just mentioned uh an 82 year
old or will be 82 year old house speaker
nancy pelosi who's speaking in numbers
by the way is at 33 approval in the real
clear politics average so not exactly
running in great numbers either look the
party needs to get younger as in born
after black and white tv was a thing
younger and nancy pelosi embodies
everything about the swamp existing to
hold on to her power and little else
because how else can you explain what
she has done to help the people in her
home district of san francisco
skyrocketing crime drugs homelessness
and you almost never hear her talk about
it talk about actual solutions and by
the way you can save the tape she's not
going to be speaker of the house a red
tsunami is coming that's going to sweep
her out with about 40 to 50 seats to
spare and the squad wing of the party
they're going to ensure that she will
not even be house minority leader after
taking such a shellacking carly this is
also not welcome news to a lot of
democrats here is cnn contributor bakari
sellers listen to what he had to say
i firmly believe that it's time for new
leadership in the house democratic
caucus i think it's a time for new
leadership um throughout the democratic
party not only do we have to get younger
but we have to be more vibrant and we
have to have bigger and bolder ideas to
bring in a new generation of voters
there comes a time whether or not you're
nancy pelosi or whether or not you're
you know tom brady that that sometimes
you have to hang up the cleats when it
comes to you know being leader of your
particular party or leader of your
organization
so joe does that comment show the divide
within the democratic party
oh completely right bakari sellers is
probably a good 40 years younger than
nancy pelosi and people just don't want
to see the same old leadership that has
failed over the last year by the way can
we please stop with the pelosi brady
comparisons brady's won seven super
bowls he has a history of winning on a
consistent basis you tell me how many
wins nancy pelosi has had lately win
valuable prizes
yeah i just think nobody likes this
other than nancy pelosi yourself and
republicans this is a campaign ad it
writes itself something everybody loves
is ice cream some people love it a
little bit too much and it really shows
how out of touch they are joe biden of
course grabbing ice cream to highlight
economic growth
look isn't this a complete failure to
read the room i mean people are
struggling to put actual nutritional
food on their table to feed their
families and this guy is going out to a
shishy ice cream restaurant to be like
look the economy is great not read in
the room right joe
yeah pyro and then white house press
secretary john saki was asked yesterday
why the president had an almost
non-existent schedule yesterday and even
she had trouble spinning the answer well
it turns out that going for ice cream on
a random tuesday and winter was a good
idea from an optics perspective because
when that optic is juxtaposed with
russian troops amassing on the border of
ukraine as you mentioned astronomical
gas prices food prices home heating
prices and by the way wouldn't it be
great if a reporter asked him hey mr
president did you get sprinkles with
with your ice cream and he responds of
course i didn't get sprinkles you stupid
son of a [ __ ] that would have been
perfect but we didn't get that question
unfortunately
this is part joe of the
biden administration's revamped effort
in year two to get the president out of
the white house out of delaware and hang
out with the american people directly
do you think it's going to work
well i don't think you go to as todd
described it as shishi ice cream place a
couple blocks down right from from the
white house i think you've got to get
out and speak to the american people in
michigan ohio wisconsin pennsylvania
nevada arizona georgia you know you've
got to get out and talk about economic
issues not again who gets ice cream in
the afternoon in the winter on a tuesday
i don't think i've ever done it yeah
also we're showing a video of him
shopping keep in mind he purchased a
kamala mug so put those two together joe
you got him buying a mug with the face
of his vice president
and then also eating ice cream meantime
vladimir putin is preparing to go to war
he's got to see this and think to
himself boy i really have no pushback
huh
i i just don't understand who is
advising the president in terms of the
things that he does on a daily basis or
does not do and you're exactly right
putin looks at this and says oh that's
what the american president's doing oh
great so some some people have to start
getting fired given the poll numbers and
i think that starts with the white house
chief of staff and ron claim when when
he isn't playing on twitter is giving
the president profoundly bad advice if
that is the person telling him to do
this if not then it's i guess a gensake
from a communications person well the
ice cream he had was salted peanut
butter ice cream with chocolate flecks
plus a scoop of blackout chocolate cake
on a waffle cone so he does have good
taste in ice cream again but people are
trying to thank you put food on a table
so yeah there you go
do you call it chocolate chip mint or
mint chocolate chip by the way
chocolate chip is there a debate
thank you i went i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now